all about you and me baby do you enjoy
watching innocent people suffer yeah let
me get me the wall Oh mal your mother
would be so proud of you you took down
the barrier and became the queen of the
world but wait a second where is your
mother you sort of ditched her in
descendants too and never looked back
are you going to help her shed her
lizard skin or let her figure things out
on her own we've put our money on the
second option after all you're super
busy now that you have a kingdom to run
and a wedding to plan the people have
spoken and they want descendants for
because as it turns out fans still have
a lot of questions that need answering
watch until the end to find out who the
new core for would be new leading ladies
mal has always been the star of the show
but now that she's set to become queen
someone else should take her place as
the coolest BK at auradon prep we could
think of no one better than dizzy
Tremaine it's no secret that dizzy is a
fan favorite problem is we hardly got to
see her in descendants 3 we loved how
close dizzy and Celia were which is why
fans would love it if d4 centered around
these two leading ladies they would make
mal and EB so proud the new wave we
never got to see the B case graduate
from auradon prep which is a total
bummer we would love to see the V case
in a case throw their caps up in
celebration if there's one thing fans
would love to see in descendants 4 it's
a new wave of BK's in ak's walking the
halls at auradon prep there are so many
interesting characters we never got to
meet on the small screen keep watching
to find out which magical sisters would
make their grand debut in descendents 4
I was hoping you were home
is this a joke Audrey's bow now has been
Carlos has Jane he has dug and Jay has
Lonnie and Gil but what about the queen
of mean fans have been wondering about
Audrey's future boyfriend ever since
they saw her flirting with Harry hook at
the end of descendants three we all know
that Audrey hasn't been the nicest
person but she wants to change so we
really want to see her get the happily
ever after she always dreamed of and
let's face it
chad charming isn't the guy of her
dreams do you enjoy watching innocent
people's has anyone seen Maleficent the
question on everyone's lips is what
happened to Maleficent
surely the most powerful sorceress of
all time won't be married to her lizard
body for much longer
fans want to see Maleficent make a grand
comeback in d4 it would be so
interesting to see mal and her mom face
off for a second time Maleficent would
undoubtedly be squeamish after spending
so much time as a reptile do you think
she would forgive mal or seek revenge on
her daughter's newfound kingdom tell us
in the comments what about uma as it
turns out uma is as selfless as they
come she sacrificed her freedom to help
her people and didn't garner any titles
in the process we thought that OMA would
be appointed the rightful ruler of the
Isle of the laws but that just didn't
happen we'd love to see Houma and mal
working together in descendants for uma
could become one of Mao's royal advisers
and start making a difference for DK's
everywhere we'd also love to see uma
fall in love she may be a former villain
but the pirate still deserves her
happily ever after Gil and Jai's epic
adventure Gil and Jai totally hit it off
midway through descendants three their
bond was so explosive it was sure to
make Harry and Carlos a little jealous
we loved how they made plans to tour the
world but we sort of wish that we could
catch a sneak peak of their epic
adventure how fun would it be if mal
received a magical postcard from Gil and
Jai at the beginning of d4 they would
probably be surfing on a whale's back
with huge grins on their faces
the reunion we know belen beasts are
going to attend Benin mouths wedding but
what about Hades in Maleficent if
there's one musical number we need to
see in v4 it's a duet sung by Hades and
Maleficent Dan's want to get the full
scoop on their relationship they need to
know why and how it came to an end no I
left your mother Hades and Maleficent
have some unfinished business which is
why their duet would be the song of the
ages Elsa and Anna Elsa and Anna are
nowhere to be found
fans would love it if Elsa and Anna had
small roles in descendants for it would
be so fun to see them dropping their
kids off at school and you never know
they might even help dizzy and Celia
form the new core for the merge now that
the barrier has been taken down things
are going to change in auradon for good
fans are curious to find out how the
fashion in auradon will change now that
the BK's and ak's have merged together
they'd also like to see how the ak's
Envy Ches interact with one another have
they let bygones be bygones or have they
continued to oppose each other the royal
wedding but the most anticipated moment
of descendants four has to be Benin
mouths royal wedding if d4 doesn't end
up happening fans hope that the Disney
Channel will at least release a short
film of Benin mouths wedding what do you
want to see in descendants for sound off
in the comments hit that subscribe
button and don't forget to give this
video a big thumbs up thanks for
watching the things we'll see you next
time
[Music]